good evening everyone I am in fact
Dwayne Johnson and you are watching the
Graham Norton Show this is cool though
so your mother a big fan but Brad Pitt's
oh man that was the best night of my
life yes
[Applause]
slippers no yeah there was this auction
thing that happened and I done what they
called me and said would you you know do
you want to do you want to auction
something off like maybe sort of an
experience watching the show with you or
something and I was like okay if it's
lovely it's great for charity it'll be
for some you know some something yeah
and it'll be fine I get there when it's
basically like this what it's basically
it's the Oscars that there's so many
celebrities in this room and I suddenly
remember that I said that I would
auction something off and so the fear
grows so I was petrified absolute
petrified and then the person whose
table I was on is her friend and he was
being very kind and kind of put the
paddle up and I was like thanks very
much that's very sweet that'll be that
and then someone else's paddle up went
up across the other side of the room and
I didn't really know and then suddenly
it was sort of becoming a bit of money
and I was kind of thinking oh this is
absolutely mental and someone went it's
Brad Pitt Nariman he's pedal up paddle
one of those people they deliberately
don't say plot details - I am I
definitely am but did you let something
slip in the past why do they think
you're going to tell everyone I just
tell everyone and I just wasn't allowed
to read the script you know so I'd be on
set and I'd be working with actors and
actresses that were just tennis balls
for that day so I'd be texting people
like hey are you in this scene with
spider-man and they'd be like no about
ok can watch just cross that one off
that list of 40 people are you in this
scene so I just basically had to do a
lot of background research to figure out
is there like a superhero watsapp group
hosted videos of your of your workouts
here's one of the videos of you working
out
[Applause]
[Music]
I know for sure you did because it was
very indirect you were in that bathroom
admit it I was I filmed it looking at is
your dress covered in what I think it's
yes it is it's very interesting do you
see that or do you see Fenster your face
it's a roaster what are you thinking
about when you're seeing model is really
when you look anything over there I was
at a wedding once and during the
ceremony was a big church and during the
ceremony a little boy you know we do you
take this woman burner and this little
boy jumped up and started running down
the sort of aisle tripped and vomited
everywhere because if you've got a go if
he's got to come out I I went on a
school trip to the House of Lords this
is I like it if you wanna involve
sonship
the coach they are taking one off
anywhere they find it we find it fun in
the House of Lords I went I thought if I
just go very still and swallows I'm so
sorry really Lords in all over the red
velvet seat and my teacher to turn
around say disgusting
running around with wipes at school I
thought this was like recently so
there's quite a sort of sweet tender
moment yes so what happens there can I
show you
[Applause]
[Laughter]
if everybody would like to join in there
feel free to this is one of my favorite
moments in the show it's a it's a slow
dance when's the last time you've slow
dance with somebody years you can dance
with your partner's next to you or yes
music please
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh Oh the cameras were broken we've got
to do that again did you run it past
Josh that you were going to evolve is
his stepmom in the movie oh yeah
Barbra Streisand no no I didn't talk to
Josh he just said yeah yeah no no you
didn't he thought I was kidding I was
like no I did and then there was I can't
really talk about there was a point
where I heard this song can I say well
coming out of your mouth yeah keep going
no no I like offset which seems a little
tragic I was filming in New York and New
York overseas the home of the character
so some of it had to take place there
and we were on his street more on
Bleecker Street
I just around the corner was a cafe and
it was in New York as I think in a lot
of America you the perhaps can just the
paparazzi can get in front of the camera
they go hey get out of my shot to the
DOP who's moving the camera around so
it's it's extraordinary and they were
everywhere this day they were just there
were more of them than they were crew so
this is getting a little rude because
they can't follow me into a cafe surely
and the man no they can't but your cafe
I went yeah it's a French word for a
coffee house I'm gonna go around the
Coco I went into sorry normal Americans
too stupid I didn't mean
listen
[Applause]
[Music]
you